hi everyone this is Jerry and this is
another live blitz game I just put a
seek out for a five-minute game for a
nineteen hundred plus player ok this is
a game against a 1904 player I'm gonna
go with the birds opening I have yet to
play this opening in live blitz and I'm
trying to get a variety of different
openings trying to show a variety of
different openings for the live blitz so
if you have suggestions feel free to let
me know if I a comment so a lot of the
well actually what I wanted to do was
play b3 and Bishop b2 but he really
didn't give me the opportunity to do
that because a lot of the focus is
centered around the e5 square f4 9 f3
both of those moves are focused on e5 so
I think I have to sort of change my game
plan I think I'm gonna play d4 this is
creating a hole so I have to take care
of this square now but I'm doing that so
that I could play Knight here it's sort
of like a little stone wall setup so I
just got play here right now since this
pawn is blocking a few Bishop here
actually I'll have to watch over this
pawn in case the knight comes here to be
attacking this pawn as soon as I play
here this is unprotected so something
they need to watch out for okay so yeah
he's attacking that so how to defend
Queen here here because I want my knight
to eventually come here but then again I
don't want to wait around for his Knight
to move in order for me to untangle
myself from the protection of this pawn
so play here right now I think he was
gonna be a move and I play here first
actually maybe maybe c4 for c4 and the
knight c3 okay so he's headed towards
this square right now so I'm gonna
defend if here takes takes and then
Knight here and then there's there's
tension between the bishops
my queen is potentially I'm protected in
some variations where the bishop takes
the knight so I have to be careful of
that
since my Knights taken
okay so my queen is now gonna be in an
unprotected state so I take like this I
lose this pawn takes takes takes and
then let it be a four so I have to take
like this so I've essentially repaired
the hole that was here you know hold by
definition of square that can't be
protected by any pawns excluding pollen
captures but this is an instance where I
capture with the pawn and now I have
coverage over this square so that was I
mean its main purpose was so that I
didn't lose a pawn on c4 so what do I do
in the meantime I think rook a to d1
would be a sensible move
maybe followed up with expansion with E
for I think the idea is going to be to
try and put pressure on this pawn or
maybe actually maybe I should push here
and then do do like B for B if I try to
open something up along the B file yeah
I think I'm gonna go or maybe maybe
Bishop here as a result of this move
this Knights unprotected then I could
put them in a pin I think I'm going to
trade a mine Bishop for the night
close up the position and then go forth
with this sort of pawn advance and play
along the B file and in the meantime my
structure will be on dark square so I'll
be able to counteract this Bishop I'm
gonna go for this and then take and then
push forward and then push push
well maybe I won't take right away maybe
I'll kind of be annoying maybe because
this is a move that I'll probably be
wanting to make so I'll do this now I
don't like I'm just alleviating the pin
right away so that's why I'm opting not
to take on this square right away okay
so he's out of the pin
am I really fearing this Knight coming
here actually I could win upon now as a
result of this move takes takes and then
Queen takes pawn I don't see anything
wrong with that rook on the seventh
actually just you know placing even if
this pawn wasn't on b7 I think just rook
to b7 might be a good move
in and of itself so if you could try and
assign more than one reason for you know
making a move and tried to do that so
not only am i capturing a pond but I'm
placing my rook on the seventh rank
where there's a lot of potential in that
of the a7 pond the night a lot of pieces
are either directly or indirectly in its
view so pawn here the Queen here my rook
is unprotected there's pressure against
d4 I think maybe push pawn push pawn
push and then Knight here or something
Knight here is met with Queen here and
they'd hear Queen here double Roxy takes
takes I'll have double isolated pawns
I'm just going to push under 2-minutes
so this is um he's got a time advantage
so if he takes I think I recapture with
my knight and then it's a centralized
knight on a light square I guess I have
to watch out maybe my rook might be
trapped okay so I'm Queen here attacking
that take do I do I defend actually if I
defend he could insert he gonna put a
piece in between those two so I'm going
to retreat to a square right here so I
could still potentially double Brooks
and I'm watching over my knight so he's
got pressure against this pawn here I'm
gonna play pawn push now pawn here yeah
I'm gonna support my central pawn if he
takes here that's a blunder I believe
because Knight here here and then I got
pressure and then uh I'll end up winning
his knight Knight takes would just
result in Queen here
I'm gonna get out of this pin you could
win a pond take stakes but then his dark
squares are vulnerable I'm gonna go with
this Queen takes pawn oh you went for
the Queen trade um I have less than a
minute so let's see if I could just uh
dust this guy off quick what does he do
here in the meantime my king is probably
gonna find a safe haven right here I
pretty much want to get him close to the
center so let's just go with that King
here rook to d1 maybe push push yeah
rook d1 push push let me go with that
this Knights a bit annoying it's on the
edge of the board but it's on these two
squares and my rooks have to since
they're dark squares that it can go to I
constantly have to watch over these
scores with my rooks so I don't like
having to be in that sort of position
but I guess I have to work with it for
right now if I if I would have actually
I was thinking if I push here the rook
could take this pawn but not yet I'm
thinking of just maybe actually pushing
here first d6 and then here and then
I'll have a connected passed pawn so
actually I'm gonna go for that here and
then here connected passed pawn so even
in this endgame phase I still want to
coordinate my pawns with my only Bishop
my bishops on light squares I want my
pawns on dark squares so my pawns
responsible for guarding dark my bishops
are responsible for guarding light
Bishop here to here just trying to
remove the blockade or so he has more
potential and just get rid of him and I
want to create an open file so my rook
could maybe that's just a blunder Wow
maybe maybe he meant rook here maybe
that was just a mouse slip yeah that's
game over
yeah I think it was winning at that
point anyhow let me just go back quickly
to this point right here
I think if he instead went so after pawn
here if you played rook here I think
that might have been a different story
he constantly has to watch as a result
of these this is a connected past pawn
so if I could somehow get one of my
rooks active and on this seventh rank I
think I'd be in good shape that's that's
why that's what prompted this sort of
move I push to h5 or h4 so I could push
h5 and after some sort of an exchange
there'll be some open file either on G
or H maybe both and then my rook and
swing over in this direction and maybe
get on the seventh but rating and
commenting is always are appreciated and
I hope you enjoyed the video thanks bye